hey youtubers is charlie so a bunch of
Star Wars footage dropped i cobbled some
things together so check it out we'll
break it down at the end Jane whatever i
do i do it to protect you
see you understand understand
we have intercepted a coded Imperial
transmission it indicates that a major
weapons test is imminent we need to know
how to destroy it so why me the message
was sent by your father they call it the
desktop
it's capable of destroying an entire
planet it could be the end of us all
as a way to defeat him you need to
capture the plan
if you're really doing this I want to
help we'll need a team
she wants to fight
you almost shot me no well call
the power that we are dealing with
is immeasurable
97.6 percent chance of failure
I'll go shuttle what's your call sign
it's some rogue rogue one have no idea
what come
make 10 men zhi like a hundred
just take the next chance
the next
until we win the chances are spent
the Empire's building a weapon capable
of destroying an entire planet we have
to capture the plans if there's any hope
of destroying it how will you do any
make 10 men feel like a hundred
welcome to rogue one
if the Empire has this kind of power
what chance do we have
rebellions are built on hope
so something we haven't seen a lot of
before and all this rogue one footage is
actual space battles so whereas in star
wars the force awakens taking place you
know a long long time after this happens
so ship design has changed a lot you
have to remember that we're in a time
right before episode 4 so pretty much
all the ships from the original trilogy
will be featured in this like everything
will look very familiar even though all
the characters with a few exceptions
will be different I'll talk about that
too thin Mendelsohn is that a lot of
cool stuff about his villain or so
krenek in how he fits into the power
structure of the Empire he talked about
it kind of like the Empire's this
stratified high class versus low class
structure whereby he could only achieve
a certain level of notoriety because he
comes from very low beginnings so he's
really pissed off about that because
he's almost smarter than people like
random off Tarkin but the way the actor
paints his relationship with the
Imperial Council is that they're very
much like upper-class you know classic
old-world British royalty and they don't
want to have anything to do with him so
they've kind of banished him off to this
side project even though it's a really
big deal so he feels like the Death Star
is his way to make a name for himself so
you can kind of see they're trying to
paint him as something of an antihero
within the Empire even though he himself
does very terrible things that's why he
sounds the way he does he doesn't sound
like the other commanding officers that
you met on the Death Star in episode 4
they said they did that very consciously
like when he was getting ready to be in
the movie he said you know what kind of
accent should I have should I have a
very upper-class British accent and they
were like no no we don't want your
character to be like that like he's not
part of this Imperial Club of ruling
officers so he's viewed as an underdog
within the Empire but it's all part of
them trying to introduce some more
complexity into the empire but of course
the Empire would be super racist super
classist and super sexist so you'll see
some of that play out in the movie but
the other cool stuff you see them
testing the superlaser so they're going
to have like a small version of what
happened in Episode four when they blew
up Alderaan so there's a little bit more
Darth Vader footage I'll be interested
to see what his relationship with or so
krenek is
like because he does not suffer fools
but the interesting thing if you've been
reading the star wars comics is that
Darth Vader recognizes people of value
so he's still the terrible Vader that
you remember but if he sees someone that
he senses will be able to help him do
something he'll go out of his way to
help them achieve their task so he might
try to help out or Socratic in a very
dark Vader type way like he's not a nice
person but if you're really awesome with
what you do and you're building a giant
super laser for the Empire then Darth
Vader is probably going to try and help
you out but everything looks fantastic
I'll be really interested to see where
this movie leaves off with these
characters I don't think we all expect
them to survive just because the mission
that they're on is such a big deal but
obviously we know that the rebels get
the plans so they are successful but you
know like the big question is what
happens to Jen or so does she die is she
going to be in any of the other spin-off
movies we know about the han solo movie
they've been talking about doing a Yoda
movie a Boba Fett movie there's a number
of ways if they want to bring the gin or
so character back for her to be in those
other movies you can only shoehorn her
into so many situations like you know
how big is she in the life of Han Solo
so you guys let me know what do you
think about the footage and how do you
want them to use these characters in the
other spin-off movies the ones that
survive I think a couple of them will
definitely die but are there been a lot
of theories about how gin or so is
connected to people in the main trilogy
in the force awakens those characters
they've already debunked the Rays mother
theory but that doesn't mean that she's
not connected to some of the other rebel
characters or even the first-order
characters so it's still kind of up in
the air but there have been rumors that
we might see some star wars episode 8
stuff happening around the rogue one
release the bad rumor that I've heard
then it's just a rumor so doesn't mean
that it's true is that Lucasfilm is
worried that people will confuse the
timelines too much so if you drop
episode 8 footage with rogue one people
will get really confused about what is
happening where and why characters and
one movie aren't appearing in the other
movie so you can do like the giant
facepalm like everybody watching this
video probably isn't worried about that
you know exactly where rogue one takes
place in the timeline and you know when
the new trilogy takes place so if we do
not get a star
episode 8 teaser before the end of the
year just blame everybody that doesn't
understand that rogue one is a prequel
and it takes place during the timeline
of the original trilogy not during the
new films that I will totally do some
more star wars episode 8 videos when we
get closer to rogue one coming out so be
sure to subscribe to get everything we
have learned some stuff about the movie
like Luke Skywalker why he supposedly
doesn't have his lightsaber and any of
the images that people are talking about
I think it's really just in service of a
big twist like Return of the Jedi style
twist because we have Anakin Skywalker
now that's with Ray she'll be using that
and then in some big moment Luke
Skywalker would get his back we'll get
to see some really cool lightsaber
fights but there'll be plenty more
episode 8 stuff happening later this
year so get height while you guys wait
for my next video if you haven't seen it
in a while they post an episode 80s or a
long time ago you can click here to
watch that and you can click here for a
really cool spider-man homecoming
interview video thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight me me me me
[Music]